[Musik]
sebastian lee gezeigt wie die industrie
bei doppel keksen tricks und lüftet das
geheimnis warum das eigentlich keine
schokoladen kekse mehr sind doppel kekse
kennen viele von uns schon seit ihrer
kindheit aber auch wenn die füllung nach
schokolade schmeckt drin steckt keine
[Musik]
denn laut lebensmittelgesetz muss
schokolade auf jeden fall zwei stoffe
enthalten die aus kakaobohnen gewonnen
werden kakaopulver und kakaobutter
während kakaopulver billig ist zählt die
kakaobutter zu den teuersten städten der
welt
am liebsten würde die industrie deshalb
die kakaobutter komplett durch andere
fette ersetzen
das aber verhindert die kakao verordnung
die fordert mindestens 18% kakaobutter
und 14 prozent kakao trockenmasse für
alles was sich schokolade nennt
[Musik]
doch wie ist das bei schokocreme es zum
beispiel im doppel keks
[Musik]
für unseren schoko keks brauchen wir
eine richtig cremige füllung der
hauptbestandteil ist fett wie die
industrie nutzt sebastian dafür
geschmolzenes palmfett das macht rund 50
prozent seiner creme füllung aus und
kostet nur ein viertel von kakaobutter
zucker ist nicht nur günstig er wirkt
auch als geschmacksverstärker
das ist auch nötig denn an der
aromatischen hauptzutat wird kräftig
gespart
jetzt kommt der hauptakteurin spiel aber
nicht so viel chaos teuer
nur fünf prozent kakaopulver landen in
der schüssel
tatsächlich gleicht das bereits aus um
einen schokoladigen geschmack zu
erzeugen
schokocreme marke billigheimer ganz nach
gusto
[Musik]
[Applaus]
den schmelz am war die farbe ist auch da
im kühlschrank wird die creme
schnellhardt doch kann sie auch mit
echter schokolade mithalten
[Musik]
dazu haben wir sie in einem und gerechte
täglich in form gebracht und bieten sie
marktbesuchern zur verkostung an
bemerkten die tester den schwindel
[Musik]
so gemütlich und rustikal boden oder
sowas immer ganz leicht und sanft
[Musik]
keinem unserer tester fällt auf dass es
sich hier gar nicht um schokolade
handelt manche vermuten sogar eine
spezialität aber ich würde es nicht
sagen das ist ein zuschlag bekommen will
ich in einem spezialgeschäft gehört für
schokolade
warum nur fallen die testperson so
leicht auf eine billige schokoladen
nachahmung herein
[Musik]
ein teil der antwort liegt im
verwendeten fed
denn eine eigenschaft von kakaobutter
hat auch das günstige palmfett sebastian
zeigt welche das ist dazu führt er 2
bottiche mit wasser und erwärmt sie
vorsichtig auf menschliche körper
temperatur kakaobutter palmfett wie das
schmilzt bei 37 grad das sehen wir jetzt
hier auch in unserem mund herrschen
knapp 37 grad
und so entsteht dieses unvergleichliche
gefühl dass fett schmilzt auf der zunge
kühlt dabei ein klein wenig und setzt
gleich darauf fettlösliche aromen frei
mit einem wort schmelz das experiment
zeigt in sachen schmelz steht palmfett
der kakaobutter in nichts nach
für das mundgefühl von schokolade reicht
das nur darf so ein produkt laut cacau
verordnung nicht schokolade heißen
doch schoko schock oder schoko ist nicht
verboten
[Musik]
der schoko begriff ist gesetzlich nicht
definiert das heißt wir haben hier keine
vorgaben muss schokolade enthalten seien
oder nicht das gilt nur für das wort
schokolade
findige hersteller nutzen das aus für
verbraucher klingen schoko oder job
durchaus nach schokolade
erlaubt ist die spitzfindigkeit bei
vielen produkten zb bei schoko
brotaufstrich etikett und name verheißen
schokolade drin ist palmfett und ein
hauch cacau
[Musik]
das gilt auch für den schoko überzug auf
fertigkuchen er besteht stadt aus
schokolade nur aus kakao haltiger fed
blase
doch nicht alles was schoko schock oder
so ähnlich heißt ist automatisch
minderwertig einige produkte mit solchen
kürzel namen enthalten durchaus echte
schokolade
doch nicht immer steht das wort
schokolade auch explizit auf der packung
oder in der zutatenliste nur insider
finden sich da noch zurecht
[Musik]
der schoko trick ist natürlich für
verbraucher absolut verwirrend hier
könnt ihr natürlich der gesetzgeber ran
gehen und sagen wo schoko shop oder
etwas ähnliches drauf steht muss auch
schokolade enthalten seien im moment
hilft dem verbraucher nur die
zutatenliste so richtig gut aus der
schoko trick ein ärgerliches weil wir
spielen mit worten und zutaten
was liegt das schön nach schokolade auch
sebastian könnte seine schokokekse ohne
echte schokolade so verkaufen so in
schokotraum kein richtig günstig sein
mit ordentlich viel fett
worauf achtet ihr beim kauf von schuco
produkten sagt es uns in den kommentaren
und wenn ihr noch mehr über euer essen
wissen wollt dann abonniert die zdf
besser esser und schauten die nächsten
zwei klicks